de plus en plus de gens qui suppriment
leur compte facebook mais où vont tous
ces gens twitter c'est plus en plus de
jeunes sur twitter aujourd'hui c'est
pour une raison simple c'est parce que
c'est le réseau social où les parents ne
sont pas encore dessus tu as vu j'ai un
facebook maintenant c'est bien papa tu
fais quoi là
non non elle incité sur un truc de ton
téléphone c
[Musique]
je regarde ma vie est envoyé un pote ah
oui là peut-être besoin qu'on les change
sa couche s'est vu ton papa il est un
peu à la mode alors pour les gens qui
vivent dans une grotte elle même à
l'intérieur d'une grotte twitter qu'est
ce que c'est c'est un service qui permet
de poster depuis son ordinateur ou son
téléphone des messages de 140 caractères
appelé aussi tweets les autres
utilisateurs peuvent s'abonner à vos
tweets
ils deviennent donc des followers et
vous pouvez même suivre des célébrités
comme gad elmaleh
booba ou cyprien petite difficulté
supplémentaire le hashtag dans un tweet
on peut mettre un mot précédé d'un diez
pour indiquer le thème
alors bien sûr il ne faut pas utiliser
les hashtag dans la vraie vie tu sais
j'ai passé une très bonne soirée en ta
compagnie peut-être qu'après on peut les
boire un verre chez moi sexe fellation
reprend bien trop bien sodomie et comme
je suis un petit peu un vieux de twitter
puisque j'ai créé mon compte en juin
2007 je vais vous mettre sur le droit
chemin
5 tweet à éviter numéro un
le tweet à une célébrité justin bieber
je te kiffe trop répond stp je pense que
ça doit lui faire plaisir un message
comme ça
ça doit le toucher au fond de son coeur
parce qu'il est sensible il s'en bat les
couilles
donc à moins que vous aimiez parler tout
seul à midi j'ai mangé des lasers genre
de tweets ne sert à rien numéro 2 le
tweet mensonges tous mes numéros 3
retweeter à tous ses followers un tweet
qui parle de soi moi quand je vois
quelqu'un qui re tweetent un tweet qui
parle de lui je vois ça savate en tee
shirt
il a dit que mon t shirt était sympa non
mais t'es con numéro 4 les tweets
bonjour tout le monde et onu a tous à
quel moment de l'histoire de l'humanité
ce genre de tweets intéresser quelqu'un
on sait quand tu vas te coucher là il
est 4h du mat
non non je ne peux pas je peux pas tant
que
numéro 5 des tweets à éviter les tweets
à vous même pourquoi ça n'arrive qu'à
moi j'aurais pas dû me lever ce matin un
tweet que vous seul pouvez comprendre
pourquoi un
autant l'écrire sur un bout de papier le
ranger dans une pochette que vous
jetterez la poubelle c'est le même
résultat pourrait bien sûr si vous
préférez les photos il ya toujours le
service
instagram qui permet de publier des
photos avec des filtres sympa et qui
sait peut-être que votre photo va
devenir populaire c'est pas notre fort
of tucson quand on regarde les photos
populaire sur instagram
il y a des filles bonne défi bonne des
filles bonne des filles bonne défi bonne
et filles bonne des filles bonne des
fibres animales mignon et des filles
bonne dire qu'il y en a qui essaye
d'être populaire en postant une photo de
coucher de soleil
il faut montrer ses nichons maintenant
il vous reste plus qu'une seule chose à
faire
me suivre sur twitter et sur instagram
compris
[Musique]